Welcome to Unit 6. The big idea in Unit 6 is recursive definitions and we'll see
how to use a recursive definition of popularity to make the search engine
respond with the best page for a given query instead of just giving us all the
pages. This is really a key advance that made Google so successful. The real
goal of this unit is to give you infinite power. I know what you're thinking, I
have infinite power already, and you're right. You've had infinite power since
Unit 2 when you learned about procedures and if. And that was enough to write
every possible computer program. But we went on to introduce while, to use a
while loop to find all the links in a page. And that really should not have been
necessary. If you already had infinite power, you wouldn't have needed anything
new to do that. What we're going to see in this unit is that you could do that
without while, that all you really need is procedures, and by thinking about
things recursively, you can solve lots of problems in interesting ways.